bitcoin whales have been driving price
all year long now when we talk about
whales we're specifically talking about
accounts that have at least 50 million
dollars and what we can see is that
since the beginning of the year the
whales have been responsible for driving
the price up from 30 000 to 64 000
they've been responsible for that
selling pressure from 64 down to 30 and
they've also been driving the recovery
back up to about 50 000
or so and so we've got a whole bunch of
charts that we're going to pull up here
but first we've got a quote from naeem
islam i believe is how you pronounce it
i'm probably saying that wrong i
apologize uh which is the whale's
activity has been linked to price
movement since the beginning of 2021
these investors were the driving force
between behind the rally seen in
february they were the driving force
behind the price drop in march and april
when they sold off their holdings to
gain returns at peak prices the beauty
of bitcoin is that everything is on a
public ledger we can see
the movement of bitcoin we can see who
holds what we can see when they bought
it there is so much data here i
personally believe that the on-chain
analytics is going to become the most
important data in all of finance and
it's there for free for anyone to look
at and so other places you will not see
the coverage of the on-chain analytics
of bitcoin like you're going to see here
first before we get to on-chain
analytics though let's look at some of
the charts that we have we've got
bitcoin whale buying going on this
bitcoin whale buying is large investors
holdings versus the bitcoin price you
can see that since the end of 2020
pretty much when the price goes up the
whales buy when the price goes down the
whales sell it's not that difficult to
break it down but still having the data
is important then we outsourced the
bitcoin or the best business share
research team we outsourced a little bit
to cnbc they were kind enough to put
together this for our research team and
the percent change in bitcoin price over
the 28-day moving average you can see
that that volatility is still
not that crazy
right if you look at the actual
volatility of this thing the percent
change in bitcoin price on a 28-day
moving average is within a band of plus
or minus two percent
not really that crazy
then if we go and we look at
the filtered charts for a 1 000 to 100
000 bitcoin this is specifically coming
from glass nodes looking at the people
who have 1 000 to 100 000 bitcoin
overlaid with the price and you can see
that as they gain more and more bitcoin
in those wallets
the price goes up as whales buy price
goes up as well sell price goes down now
the reason why we're telling you this is
because in the last 48 hours the young
wizard will clemente
he sent out a little note he basically
called attention to something that's
very interesting we've been talking
about this bitcoin supply squeeze now
the bitcoin supply squeeze thesis is
essentially the idea that there are 70
of bitcoin that have not moved in the
last six months
if you account for lost coins 80
of bitcoin has not moved and so when you
start to think about the fact that of
the circulating supply 70 or 80 percent
is being held by these strong hands they
are not willing to sell and as we get
increasing demand like the 1.2 million
people the most on record that join the
bitcoin network in july of 2021
the price should continue to appreciate
that's what's happened we went from 30
000 to 50 000 pretty incredible
but over the last couple of days we've
seen that there are more bitcoin moving
on to exchanges over the last few weeks
we had seen the bitcoin moving off of
exchanges so this gold line here you can
see that that uh as they came off as it
drops that means that people are taking
bitcoin off exchanges as people take
bitcoin off exchanges it means that they
are not on the exchange to sell into the
market so it is a signal that people are
saying i bought bitcoin i'm gonna take
it off into cold storage and i'm gonna
hold it there there's a strong hand
component to doing that as we saw a very
big drop in that bitcoin on exchange we
saw price rise now we're starting to see
a little uptick over the last couple of
days and that's what will called out
yesterday is the fact that as the
uh number of bitcoin on exchanges ticks
up we have to be careful that we do not
see a drop in price now that could be a
short-term drop simply people taking
some sort of profits but it also could
have long-term implications i'm not
selling my bitcoin i don't think my
brothers are selling their bitcoin but i
do think that it's worth paying
attention again in the traditional world
we would have to wait for quarterly
reports to know who was buying and
selling what the beauty of the on-chain
metrics is that they don't lie we know
pretty much instantaneously or very very
close kind of near real time exactly who
is doing what and that is why i believe
that the transparent
ledger that's provided by the bitcoin
network is going to ultimately end up
being the standard when it comes to
value transfer globally
now while all of this is occurring we
have to remember that bitcoin operates
within a macro environment so the micro
environment of bitcoin we can look at
on-chain metrics we can look at all
sorts of data in terms of holders what
they're buying selling how much where
etc but we cannot lose sight of the
macro environment if you go back to uh
march of 2020 it didn't matter what the
on-chain metrics were saying about
bitcoin the macro environment was that
there was a global pandemic and it led
to a
financial crisis or a recession where
there was a liquidity crisis and all
asset prices sold off the macro
environment actually ended up
superseding the micro environment of
bitcoin the reason why i call that out
is although we do see more bitcoin
moving on to exchanges at the same time
yesterday we hit the all-time high for
the percent of households and non-profit
organizations directly and indirectly
holding corporate equities as a
percentage of financial assets that's
right this is all the way to q1 2021 but
we are now over 40 percent 40 percent of
u.s households and nonprofit
organizations directly or indirectly
hold corporate equities
pretty nuts 40
of their financial assets that number is
wild and so that is the macro situation
is that we are getting continued
manipulation of markets we're seeing
interest rates stay low persistently
we're seeing high rates of inflation
people are running to things like stocks
or cryptocurrency they're looking for
some sort of safe haven and so as we see
people continue to invest we have to
continue to watch the on-chain metrics
of bitcoin and it should tell us with
some level of accuracy where the price
likely is to go in the short term over
the long term i remain incredibly
bullish because bitcoin is the best
global store of value over the last
decade and i think that will only
continue moving into the future
what's up guys bang bang thanks so much
for watching the best business show
today if we're gonna be the best
business show we obviously need the best
partner that's why the exclusive sponsor
the best business show is sofi they're
an all-in-one platform that allows you
to invest in all kinds of different
assets including stocks etfs crypto ipos
and they even have an automated
investing function if that's your thing
so before we start getting after it
again make sure that you go download
sofi you get an invest account and when
you make your first crypto trade
regardless of what you buy they'll give
you 10 in bitcoin for free it's that
simple head on over to sofi.com to get
started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]